working as journalists in China isn't
straightforward and here in Xinjiang
it's particularly tricky scrutiny of the
government's war on terror job isn't
welcome so it means switching hotels
every night checking in late checking
out early here in the old Silk Road town
of kashgar we discover there only
certain hotels journalists are allowed
to stay in the ones they can monitor us
in we're trying to his hotel in Kashgar
and the receptionist is on the phone I'm
told he's on the phone to the foreigner
police's their name to inform them that
we're journalists we don't know there's
an example of the control that the
authorities including us under we try to
check into this hotel but because we're
foreigners and specifically journalists
they say they can't accept us and they
told us to try down the road posing as
tourists provides some cover from the
authorities we've left our big TV
cameras were those much smaller cameras
to do all our filming walk straight into
the middle of an anti-terror drill even
posing as tourists they didn't want us
to film any of it I had all my footage
deleted
shinjang province is the size of Western
Europe we spent a week here only seen a
fraction of it yet we've still covered
hundreds of miles a focus for us was to
get to a particular County in the south
the frontline of China's war on terror a
place that's been off-limits to all
foreigners allegations of a massacre by
the military emerged a month ago by him
just coming up to another police
checkpoint as we make our way south
towards the town car in front being
stopped but not sure yet whether we will
be
the language barrier is a particular
problem here in Xinjiang the Weger
Muslims don't on the whole speak
Mandarin Chinese they speak their own
unique language vaguely similar to
Turkish some do speak Chinese or even
English but there's another problem the
authorities are so suspicious of we Gers
that they're seen talking to foreigners
the repercussions for them could be huge
we need to protect the identity of all
those who spit us
well I've just had a chat with one man
who gave the very particular sense of
the level of resentment and anger here
he talked about the fact that young men
are not allowed to have beards that
people can't fast during Ramadan and he
was pretty emotional as he talked about
his wife he said that she normally wears
a veil but he's told her not to wear it
because if she does she'll be in danger